hey everyone I'm Lucy and I'm Dane and
with Solutions Architects working at
Amazon web services today we're going to
be talking about the skills required to
become an effective Solutions architect
and how you can gain those skills to
land a job at AWS quick pause this video
is brought to you by simply learn simply
learn offers an AWS Solutions Arctic
certification training course to help
you learn how to design plan and scale
AWS implementations this course is
aligned with the latest AWS exam and
covers skills such as AWS solution
planning and Architectural best
practices every year the demand for
professionals with AWS Cloud skills
continues to grow and here you can see
some of the roles available in the cloud
industry along with their salaries there
are options for self-paced Learning and
live boot camps and I would recommend
looking into the live boot camps because
it gives you a chance to learn from
mentors in a community or peers the
course curriculum covers a wide range of
AWS Concepts taught by experienced
instructors and you get to work on three
real-time projects the next online
bootcamp starts soon with limited spots
available so make sure you take a look
at the reviews and check out the link to
the course in the video description
below now let's get back to the video so
Dane first of all what is a Solutions
architect well that's a big question I
think we could probably spend most of
the video just talking through I guess
what the rule is and what the role is
about but for me I think a solution
architect is about helping a customer at
its core so helping a customer but from
a technical lens right so it could be
looking up documentation to help them
sort of get over a difficult problem uh
it could be helping out with some of
their solution design proposing or maybe
even inspiring some solution design on
their part right uh it could even be
building out a small proof of concept if
there's something that they want to do
to prove out if they wanted to
understand a bit more about
um so yeah I think it's a lot about just
helping a customer and having that extra
technical lens
it just at a general level so let's see
what do you think of some of the
technical skills required for a solution
architect yeah so it all comes all come
down to the solution
a specialized role then they'll have
more specialized technical requirements
but let's just say you're applying to an
associate Solutions acting role as a
general Solutions architect the
technical skills that they look for can
be broken up into five main domains so
there's networking compute databases
storage and security and they look for
technical breath across all five of
these domains and if you can show
technical depth in at least one of them
that would really help you stand out as
a candidate and Cloud knowledge is quite
useful as well it's not a strong
prerequisite but if you have some
knowledge of AWS services that can
really help you in the interview as well
so in this case you know we'll talk
about this later but getting AWS
certifications will be quite helpful
getting Hands-On with doing Cloud
projects it just shows your knowledge
and interest for cloud experience right
yeah yeah so Dan we've talked a lot
about technical skills now what do you
think are some of the non-technical
skills needed to become NSA yeah so as a
solution I can take you will spend a lot
of time in front of the customer right
so I think uh being personable is
something that's quite important uh
being able to have some of those
technical conversations at a high level
which I know sometimes is a bit tricky
coming from like an engineering or a
technical background
um so having the ability to sort of
translate to some extent um what some of
those ideas might be and be able to
present them to a more General audience
and it does depend as well right I think
there's an element of being able to
understand your audience and be able to
kind of present based on who's in the
room so often a customer might ask a
question a certain way
and there is maybe a part to just
looking around corners what they
actually might mean right what what it
you know the core of the problem is that
they're trying to solve so I think
having that ability to proactive to
upfront investigate and understand what
the core of the problem might be
um I think that's something that's very
helpful it might be easiest to just
about a lot of you know technical jargon
or technical Concepts which is not
always as helpful for a customer so
being able to sort of Step that back and
and again translate it to some extent I
think is definitely a valuable skill to
have right and also the willingness to
have those conversations so at least if
someone was interested in gaining some
of the skills that we've been talking
about where is a good place to start
yeah let's break that down again into
Technical and non-technical skills so
for the technical skills as I mentioned
certifications is a big one it's a great
way to start your Cloud Learning Journey
and even though the skills that you gain
from the certifications and the
knowledge is mostly theoretical because
you know they're multiple choice exams
it's quite helpful in just getting that
Foundation of what is the cloud what are
some Services AWS offers and then from
there you can start a cloud project for
example a 3-2 web application just
getting some hands-on experience will be
really helpful you know combining the
services that you learned from the
certifications into something that you
can present in an interview or showcase
on your resume one more way to gain
technical skills to become an effective
Solutions architect is having a look at
AWS white papers and reference
architectures these usually have been
created by Solutions Architects or
members of the technical team here at
AWS and they're a great way for you to
learn about AWS best practices when it
comes to architecting so Dane what about
the non-technical skills is there any
recommendations on how to build yeah so
I think uh looking for opportunities to
be able to you know get in front of an
audience or get in front of you and if
it's a one-on-one scenario uh being able
to present something uh and looking out
for those those opportunities even
within your team I think is definitely
valuable for practice uh I think an
awesome one that's been helpful for me
is uh looking out for a mentor right so
looking out for someone who kind of
ticks the boxes in in terms of things
that you might strive to achieve and it
might not be completely intent but maybe
there's specific skills that uh you kind
of admire in them that you'd like to
build in yourself right maybe it is in
the presenting space
um so yeah I'd kind of look out for for
a mentor connect with them and spend
some time with them there is also an
element of just knowing where you can
personally improve right so looking out
for some of the spots that uh you think
maybe you could do a little bit better
because that way you can maybe
consciously Focus some of that effort on
improving those parts as well so I think
that that's something that's at least
helped me in terms of the soft skill
side right so not just on the technical
side yeah that's a really good point you
know sort of evaluating your strength
and weaknesses and trying to figure out
what you need to improve on all right so
this brings us to the end of this video
on what are the skills required to
become an effective Solutions architect
at AWS please give this video a like if
you found it helpful and leave your
questions down in the comments below
thank you so much Shane for coming onto
the show today yep no worries and thank
you for watching this video all the way
to the end if enjoyed learning about the
skills required to become a Solutions
architect I recommend checking out this
video I made where I go through Commons
Solutions Arctic interview questions